khoảng trứ này ngày 8,5 mồn năm 2018, tại Sao Bình Cầu, Tình Tên Ninh,
sẽ ra vụ UTCN là thẳng Còn nhà dân khi một người từ vòng.
Thông tin bàn đầu, thời điểm trên, với tình thành bố mi sáo tuổi
được khiến UTCN đang nhá chỉ dụt là nổ thế hát, bố mi chính tuổi, vụ ở tình thầy Sao Bình Cầu.
Thế chỉ hát đứng trước xanh cùng hàng người em gái của mình là chỉ nổ TBS, bố mi hài tuổi
và chỉ nổ TBS nổ TBS nổ TBS nổ TBS, bố mi tư tuổi,
thành đã được khiến sẽ tông thằng vào CS, khiến chỉ đi thương nặng không qua khỏi,
sau đó, tình được khiến sẽ dụi khỏi hị trường.
Đến khoảng 18 giờ cùng ngày, lực lượng trức năng đồn biên phòng Mỹ
quý tây bác sữa thình khi đối tượng đang trên đường tổ thác,
hịt, cơ quan công an đăng tạm sữa thình để vụ cụ công tắc được chạm.